I want to hear your process for when
this partner approached you did you try
to talk yourself out of working with
this person oh no I wouldn't there's
several but the one guy I love I don't
know if Richard would want me to give
his last now that's okay but Richard I
met Richard finger yeah I'll tell you
he's a great guy he's a Texan and and he
met me what I was speaking at story Expo
in LA a couple of years ago and and and
I was giving a lecture on action heroes
and after he says you know I'd kind of
like you to take a look at this story
but he doesn't really talk that way
around this you gotta embellish it and
and I love Jack John I mean what I'd
never heard of Jack Johnson and not only
is Jack Johnson a cool the first
african-american heavyweight champion
he's a real guy he's a superhero I mean
you can't believe what this guy did
he went he tried to race at the Indy 500
he had his own sports car I mean they
wouldn't let him because he was black
but this guy lived in 1900 and he just
acted like the Ku Klux Klan never
existed he walk went where he wanted he
did what he wanted he loved who he
wanted and he was by the way Muhammad
Ali says he was a better boxer than he
was Muhammad Ali says that and the one
guy who saw them both box because
there's a guy who found her green
magazines really old when we were mkb he
taught Jack Johnson box let me so mad
he said Jack Johnson was better and by
the way when this guy was fighting in
America the white audiences were
throwing chairs at him why he was boxing
I mean he had to dodge bottles in the
ring and he still became heavier Tambi
they passed them they prosecuted him for
the man at because he he liked to marry
white girls which at that time you did
not do and so his and then he went to
Leavenworth prison because they were so
angry at him for what the Malaysian to
what's called the Mann Act which was
Trant is called the white slavery act it
was if you transported a woman over
state well I say always just be
it was designed to prosecute whoever the
federal government to prosecute so you
put her in the Leavenworth and then the
warden was so impressed by him that he
ended up giving let him have exhibition
matches inside Leavenworth and then he
got out and he died in a car crash in 47
but again just like leonidas in 300 this
guy the interesting part of his story
was the villains got bigger and bigger
right that were that were on that were
prosecuting him the villains got bigger
and bigger at first it was just the
local folks then it became the state
cops in Chicago then it became the
federal cops all prosecuting Jack
Johnson for who he was
so this fit my super hero formula great
and and Richard kept saying well let's
just do one more he started writing it
and then I said well he was hiring me to
help him which I do I cut do consults
and you can hire me and then I'll I'll
critique your work and he finds a no
Peter I'm paying you so damn much money
to consult with me you just take half
the doggone thing and let's do it
together and that'll save me money and
so that's what we did and Richard and I
just we work so well together we're
working on another project Nero
which is a famous Roman Emperor who was
a mass murderer and kind of an antihero
I have a again III found out and figure
out how anti-heroes work have been
teaching that for some time and that
tool works great too by the way
so the tools that I'm using are the
tools that I constructed to teach with
and so far they all work there's a
couple tools I have that are crappy that
haven't turned out to work that well and
when I really put them into practice we
can talk about those too but I'd rather
talk about the ones that do work here
just real quickly I would love to hear
what just just real quickly why was he
such a threat to people and then we'll
move on Joe Johnson well first of all he
was this big beautiful black man who was
completely unscared right he was and he
was had a hat kind of
smirk whose kind of James Bond had a
little arrogance right he was just a guy
who didn't give a about your anger
at him he didn't care whether or not you
were upset with him for not following
the rules he was a rebel at a time when
if you were a black man and you were
even seen with a white woman you could
get lynched literally get lynched and he
was also a great musician he had a
nightclub act this guy did everything he
was a pop star right he played a viola
and there's film of him doing it so this
guy could do anything he was like jay-z
combined with Muhammad Ali combined with
double-oh-seven
right and and everybody all the white
authority figures hated him and he just
didn't care he did exactly what he
wanted to do so he's an amazing
character and I know we're going to get
somebody amazing to play him